you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on HS org
and I'm gonna play a 15-10 game okay
let's start with Knight f6 first time
playing this player the doctor okay
where's the doctor from Denmark okay
let's go with e6 see what white gives us
opportunity for an Enzo g3 here here
something else another thing so okay
it's a thinker all right let's go for an
Enzo Indian now it's on white classical
may be headed for a Rubinstein no just
Knight f3
alright how do I want to approach this I
probably just want a castle any other
moves I'm considering
No let's go on with castles I thought
for a moment about d5 but I want to
retain the option to take the night and
maybe play against CC pawns if I play d5
this idea in the end why done doubles
the pawns so 4 moves in it's the
quickest way you could go about castling
kingside
retaining a lot of flexibilities with
flexibility with these guys and now that
move okay
ask it a question and then and then
maybe
do something on the queenside so h6
backup if the bishop is committed to the
Kings side then I could think about c5
Queen a5 I'm gonna I'm gonna ask a
question once let's see what your
intentions are I mean I'm expecting just
the Bishop h4 move no there's a couple
ways out of this pin one I could drop
the bishop back not my first choice the
other one is to connect Knights so
getting this kind of a structure and
let's say c5 d 6 one or two steps c5 d
six connect nights and then amount
so one of the ideas here is if Bishop h4
yeah again ec5 striking at the center
the duo and then queen a5 and there
isn't there isn't time in that position
to take the knight I could take here
first with a check and then take again
winning upon though I'm kind of
recalling maybe a mmm a position where
maybe there's a gambit like that because
in the end my king side is a bit damaged
even if I went upon why could maybe
block with the night okay well that's a
bit of a surprise how do I want to treat
this well I'm just gonna recapture I
don't think I want to give up my dark
square bishop so easily Wow okay that
move was played fast so I have the
bishop pair what does white have hmm
White has
on presence uncie anyone side I had
and development wise a good general rule
is to just start breaking at the dark
squares I have an unopposed dark square
Bishop so c5 comes to mind
with the knight to c6 and the other
moves I'm considering if I go see five
and a three I think I could insert this
move and then I have an escape route if
I want to go in that direction but this
is um you know I could always just give
the bishop right back I think this makes
a whole lot of sense it's a deep on
excuse me it's a deep on based opening
the sea ponds like to contribute
striking at the center and now I'm ready
to jump in here
so a capture or push leaves the knight
vulnerable so more long
I like that I have a flight square it's
not that the greatest flight square but
well yeah yeah it is I mean he could be
controlled by pieces but it doesn't
create any holes near my kingside so
that's nice so what am i doing if rook
c1 is played rook c1 I may need to be a
little bit careful there because rooks
see one here and then a3
[Music]
Brooksie one Bishop d3 are probably the
moves I would be considering on whites
and I was just ready to flip the board
by hitting up okay you look at it from
whites perspective for a second okay
Bishop d3 in the end
so this isn't threatening to win because
in the end there's this Chuck I still
think the night just belongs here yep
let's let's put the night on this square
now what am I going to do with this guy
I have to commit at some point this will
probably be a much faster move I have to
make sure my bishop doesn't end up
getting caught like offside over here I
think I do want to exchange it for the
night but I want to be a bit careful
about the timing so on castles if I take
here and then here I straighten out the
pawns and that's just a wonderful
structure C for D for e3 that is not a
position I want to play
that's a favorable structure for white
okay so I could undo this first and then
after this then I could consider
I think I'm gonna do that let's break
this up I'm less fearful of my bishop
getting stranded so is maybe now a good
time to take the night cuz this this is
a little bit annoying must be said this
uh this idea of ninety four and then
night here that starts to concern me a
little bit actually here with tempo on
the Queen night here night here I'm a
little bit backward development wise you
know I can't rely upon this guy to
defend light squares on the Kings side
so anything else besides Bishop takes
Knight here I'm thinking about this and
then following up with a dark square
construction hmm I mean I could I could
try rookie 894 and then maybe drop my
Bishop back mmm that doesn't feel right
that seems far too slow in a position
wherever I'm still trying to complete
development and white is just one move
out from connecting rooks so I'm gonna
abandon that idea uh you know probably
just chopped the knight yeah let's not
stop any 94 business so we both didn't
care too much about our dark square
bishop but at least I have inflicted
some structural damage on White's end
or I want to move my my deep on
like that or like this I may end up with
an isolated pond but on the other hand
maybe I could get at the c3 pond hmm I
think I like this move d6 d6 with ne5
yeah I'm gonna give that a go I know I'm
happy to have an opponent who actually
takes some time to think
my it felt like my previous opponent or
to and this these are standard games I
do wear ah I don't know if it on the
speedy side so is there some kind of
caveman idea I don't think this it would
be too much of an issue I'd create two
holes but my queen is around there's
only one night I'd have to worry about
trying to sneak into these squares I
could tolerate that
here at some point I may need to play b6
if I
three moves in a row what would they be
probably this this and this yeah first
things first the ID
I want to get this bishop playing
I may need to be at I may need to be a
bit careful cuz rooked b1 if I play b6
my knight is hanging and then where
would I go here here I guess both are
fine yeah
I think any kind of pin I could just
easily get out of so I have enough
support for this move here's another
thing if I go a 5 Bishop b4 is this
going to be a problem you know what
let's just put this on and then I'll
explain even if somehow I lose this poem
the way I would lose it is first with a
capture capture even even if I lose it
a a7 and b7 negate these three this
isn't the healthiest of pond so if I
could make this pawn you know if this
pawn is exchange for my e pond these
guys are left all alone doubled and
isolated far worse than the current
position it's really the worst scenario
structurally and doubled isolated ponds
so let's see
Bishop e4 on
what I do probably just recapture with
the poem whoa
I did not consider because mmm okay I
think I see maybe an idea that my
opponent has well if I could get these
moves in if I get my knight to c5 it's
going to be a problem
so I mixed
after I move my knight and c5 is going
to be played and if I capture then my e
pawn falls where do I want to go with my
knight
I think a5 it's one of these two I want
to go to one of these two so I mean here
here and here is and I mean I might want
to go back home this would be the
fastest actually because here I have to
get this move in and then being keto the
night okay so what about I go back home
this isn't this is a very important
moment
decision time for my night choose wisely
night back home I think this is
mandatory night back home c5 Bishop g4
I'll be able to get a
and I should be able to function well on
the dark squares
back home let's see see five another one
is this maneuver but um I'll be able to
get hmm
well let's see what white does 92 or c5
is what I'm thinking anything else I
think is close to being strategically
busted for white this this actually I
think is a far too slow and here's the
other thing if the Knights are exchanged
somehow so let's say the pin is
prevented h3 ninety seven ninety two
ninety five ninety four
yeah so well I have another path as well
so even if the Knights are exchanged
I stand better because of the better
Bishop and the better structure okay
well does it really matter which path it
may it may yeah I
want to go to the edge and keep my
bishops eyes open because I still have
dreams of let's say exchanging off the
bishop for the night and then
supergluing this night in here in the
end
the queenside for white is frozen and so
I could then slowly look to play with
this majority four versus three really
the f5 and E 5 pond I could get rolling
so I think night a six here is the best
move let's do it
he's on the edge but he's ready to
become an absolute animal on c5 so I'm
expecting something like this preparing
to challenge the night and he's just he
would be too too valuable on c5 he must
be challenged
now I don't know how exactly I would
manage exchanging the bishop for a night
off because ninety-two I have to make a
queen move may have to go back home so
if 92 Queen here I'm in a pin to worry
about f4 stuff
maybe alright The Naked challenge my
night from two different posts B 3 and B
3 or e 4 on v3 it's a little clumsy I
think I think it must start with this
I'm a just
right in the
9594 takes Bishop d2 you know there's
another detail if we go for just a night
for night exchange this is gonna happen
really fast and there's there's always
this question do you play b6 to stop the
pressure and invite a four a five
cracking up the open the a file or can I
manage this some lateral defense and
then the opening up of the queenside
becomes difficult b3 is just a thought
list that's probably not the right word
just kind of a quick move that says you
know what I want to stop this kind of
pressure here and free up my pieces but
more long-term given time and I believe
White has the time would have the time
in this kind of position to get a four a
five and in the end I'm going to end up
with some kind of a target the B pond or
the a pond will be a target
is an isolated pawn I mean in short try
to not allow this isolated pond to
exchange itself off or any of my
queenside ponds that's why sometimes you
know
to combat this advanced a45 it'd be nice
to have the knight upon on b6 in the
night on a5 don't allow this pawn to
exchange and the knight is actually
quite an active piece from the a5 Square
exerting pressure on c4 can't really
pull that off that would take a a ton of
moose
so let's see roof well hmm I'm in really
good shape here let's put the knight in
so now if this now that the bishop has
been pulled off with this dog and I'm
not quite sure why that move was played
I could stop Knight e4 with Bishop f5 my
pieces start to intersect hmm I guess in
the end white
had the intention of playing c5 that I
think when we look back at this game
that must be the suggestion oops
yeah that must be the end the
suggestion by the computer as soon as I
went back home with my name okay so now
there's not even going to be a challenge
of my night this is a this is like a
five point piece maybe more so I'm ready
to go here's the other thing if I can
maintain my night on c5 I don't to worry
about this pressure so I'm playing with
a healthy for 2/3 majority in the
kingside and you know there's and
there's nothing these these pawns are
all frozen on whites Queen side so moves
to consider Bishop d7 Bishop f5 this
seems more aggressive but I still have
ideas to get this majority going
decision time
consider here another important moment
where to go with the bishop one of these
two
oh here yeah I want to keep
for this now what am i what would I be
doing exactly if I get this pond duo in
this is an important important thing to
know I could consider efore it's extra
appealing because I the night away but
where am I
flushing the night to I'm chasing and
chasing it to a good square on d4 which
may be okay because my bishop would
offset it not quite sure what the story
is with the Queen oh you know what
I could had a tactic this was the other
room to consider I have another
opportunity for I could take here and
then take here Bishop takes pawn Knight
takes e5 is the only way to maintain the
material hmm Bishop takes pawn and
five Bishop takes g2
Bishop takes pawn Knight takes e5 this
is it chop-chop I just go here and I'll
basically just winning there so Bishop
takes pawn Knight takes e5 this is a big
pond to give up so if I just immediately
recapture pawn takes Bishop mm-hmm I
want my knight on f4 in that position I
think I'll be able to
for if I get my knight to have four I
think I win or even e5
you
hmm not sure if I I'm really not sure if
I want to pull the trigger on that one
takes pawn Knight takes e5 just
immediate ryeowon here's the other thing
I don't like that I'm giving white a
connected passer there's a simpler
approach tell you what none of the above
let's go here I'm preparing to expand
computer would probably be signed to
capture the pawn I don't know I don't
like giving up this big pawn my knight
is a little bit away from getting at the
King No so he
I'm okay with bringing the Queen back
might be this I'm okay though if that
happens
this may be a mistake this a four a five
speaking of a little bit earlier it's
tough to get that in now my minors
coordinate on a four so if Knight d2
Knight b3 I think I might need to come
back over with my rook and just be okay
with playing b6 and here's the other
thing if I could get my rook on a5 and
that would seal things I stopped the
isolated pawn from exchanging itself
with my rook on a5 earlier I was
speaking about a knight on e5 rook is
just as good maybe even better that pone
can easily fall off I might have to undo
this last move if 92 is played and be
prepared to have my knight challenged to
one of these to theorize on
on beads free I don't want to take and
repair okay so now well I could in it I
could insert a check this is the first
moment where I have a check available so
I think that's a mistake
my opponents last move because now check
here I take the night check came back
somewhere and then I'm ready to take and
this is under much more favorable
circumstances I believe let's let's
let's go in for this now queen f4 and
then Bishop takes pawn okay Bishop takes
pawn Knight takes pawn I'm going to go
for it in this case
other thing I could maybe meet Knight
takes e5 with Bishop takes pawn I have
to look for some other in-between moves
by white in that position and I takes
pawn bishop takes G to 92
could take it
the g2 pond that's it's game over I
think I think this is just winning now
Knight takes e5 I'm going to
jeetu that this is a two point two point
pond maybe more depending on what pieces
are still around oh okay so now I'm just
up a clear pond okay well I need to move
my bishop okay where does my bishop want
to be just thinking about this might be
three in the night a for thou Queen a
three and then this C five move we
nineteen eighty three strikes at D six
hmm it's also Bishop f5 which is
controlling
he won our even on the clock Bishop
Bishop f5 or Bishop c8 is what I'm
considering Bishop d8 even Knight b3 I
don't want to be sick steak steaks and
then the Queen is really active
all the way back you know it's night be
three move might be three with Queen a3
concerns me this pawn is hanging so
queen a3 after being have to be careful
I may need to do this now I mean I
really have to get these pawns going mmm
have to is strong but my rooks are right
behind them so I might as well get
rolling with them I am up upon I'm
really trying to keep this as clean as
possible but I haven't I'm not too
confident with what I've come up with so
far
you
efore creates a new square for a rook
rook up and over stuff hmm okay
let's get an e for safeguards my queen I
have to worry about rook rook f3 ready
to go with this okay
rookie five yeah I want to put
protected square so I have to be careful
of the f3 move I'm still surprised that
this night hasn't been challenged oh
here's the other thing night b3 if I
don't take 94 hmm I might just work
around it try to f2 is a little bit
sensitive unprotected at the moment one
attacker one defender on f2 so this
throws a pretty strong punch
not the cleanest technique being up upon
like this could double what else is what
else am I going to do with this rook I
don't want to commit with this just yet
especially with that rook on g3 if I do
this I'm exposing some lack some
coordination on g7 I want to keep this
guy in home base home base its pawn no
I'm in a pin okay let's get a move Queen
can't go too far okay now I
the pond up here cuz that's gonna that's
gonna hurt pretty good alright how about
a kind of sidestep Queen h4 and then I
have like Queen here that seems like a
very nice consolidating position yeah a
queen here guards everything my base
points yeah
then Queen on e7 and then things should
be pretty smooth I have to worry about
any possibilities of coordinating here
this is gonna start to be painful beside
this threat let's start with this so
here here are I mean I'm already I'm
already ready for f5 f4 oh and here's
the other thing my bishop controls h3 I
was thinking that this may be a
possibility it's not this Bishop is not
playing opponent is under 2 minutes now
stay focused I have I have good
coordination here so the Queen wants the
story there I think I just get this in
now f5 let's do it this starts to be
really really serious I'm forgetting
about we're not forgetting I'm thinking
more about Queen f6 instead of e7 now in
this case okay yeah especially now
because here here threatens or takes
pawn Queen on f6 is very good move
though though though our is white ready
to do something like this now I'm ready
to have the position open up
and I can
playin up for rook maybe in some hot
water a superior queen superior night
and I think something needs to be done
with f4 right now if I get enough for oh
yeah it's a good move I think an only
move and yeah it's it's time to just
have this position open up okay how do I
want to recapture cleaner rook or pawn
or or is it worthwhile to get this in
with check hmm a sneaky pawn stab f2
what am I really gaining without maybe
something I think it's worthwhile to
invite the King to an unfavorable Square
let's do that insert a check so how
so ready to just recapture somehow I
don't want to do this I don't want to
create a passed pawn connected passer so
I'm thinking more about the Queen now
yeah because if the knight improves I
want to be able to give a check if I
take with the rook there's this nice
forward move with tempo and my rook
doesn't have a great retreat so here I
was thinking I have a check but I could
I could consider taking the pawn okay so
now I could do this and then this my
pieces are coming together yeah I think
I want to do this throw a punch at the
rook let's get it in there still up upon
I want my knight here and maybe Queen
here
where's the rip go I have coordination
maybe this square up to the Queen but no
now I have this where does the rook go
it's really really short on squares has
to go back here there's as well that
would drop the night actually
okay so rook f3 I think is the only move
Knight here okay
so Bishop g4 or do I give the Queen a
kick first Bishop f5
you
I think I want to do this just kind of
kick the Queen away from even observing
these squares and then I might go here
next mmm dummy could have gone here and
then after this capture the pawn might
be inviting the Queen doing even better
square okay where am i okay let's do
this now
I'm close to having my opponent into
Zook swung it only has this square and a
queen here
or I could do this
I might want to do this yeah just play
g5 make sure I don't drop out for really
just giving up the exchange I'm gonna
take
and I just want the Queen's off let's go
here I have this covered Queen here I'm
up upon in the exchange now two three
four five six yeah on in the exchange
okay so I can get the Queen's off where
is this these are the squares that
concern me most no not this one this one
but I have it under control so I'm just
going to go in for the Queen exchange
and make it really simple
and I'll hold this tension and it's just
a minor point but I think white is more
inconvenienced with this tension than I
am
well let's
let's let's think here for a moment
a little bit irritating night here as
well okay maybe I do initiate the
exchange yeah and I
check and then take this pawn I
go pacman mode if I get this outside
passer he's gonna not be too thrilled
King there I could go for
the bishop as well and then let my rook
go hunting yeah here take the bishop and
then boom boom I don't care if the
knight sits here it's just all about
vacuuming up pawns at this stage yeah
I'll try to go about it like this you
know let's take that you know this pawn
might be
past but my king will be able to stop it
these guys are all going to fall
so it's probably gonna go in for this
I'm gonna get this I could even cut the
King off a night in a pond alone could
not coordinate to get a queen no fancy
Forks
just take stuff just one check and let's
take here mm-hmm
and I think I just want to get over
right now with my king
okay this promotions
guarded so anything fancy got to be
careful here here takes there's no night
move with Czech king and rook around
different color squares so no Forks
right on this point I think white may
resign I am up
in the exchange and I'll be winning this
pawn and now be giving this one up may
play out a few more moves try something
like this but I could even sacrifice the
rook for the pony win the King and pawn
endgame so let's see the dis the
decision by the doctor
the critical decision was really in that
middle game allowing my neck to get to
c5
yeah they resigned okay let's see I'm
not going to die
to the analysis just yet mmm I mean okay
and different ways to play I think
Bishop h4 is I think Bishop h4 is the
more annoying move for me something like
this or c5 4 C 5 D 6 night here the
Queen i5 stuff yeah critical moment
right around here
ee 5 I think c5 needs to be played I
think I just want to dive right into it
now in C first let me click on the
computer analysis somebody already did
that and we'll see what it has to say in
just a little bit but just kind of
zipping through in this nimzo-indian 3
nights of variation question bishop h4
bishop takes f6 ok so it isn't the
biggest fan of that capture but it's
course playable c5 and then what near
bishop take
see three and doing something else like
d6 it just feels too slow
this is it's kind of Concerned me 28 I
don't know I I didn't like that my
bishops kind of cut off over here he's
not playing just yet starts to like
white even
okay so I took the night and right
around here okay d6 b6 I went with the
d6 after E 5 Bishop e4 h 3 is even
popping up H 3 was played oh no after
this point of H 3 right now ah this is
different now age 3 stopping the pin in
this position and the big difference is
that white retains some flexibility with
the D pawn it becomes a static structure
after d5 and my knight has dreams to get
to the c5 square 97-98
so this is an improvement for white age
3 or even to capture what's this about I
was planning on taking with the pond
then queen b1 ooh very computer ask this
is different story though preparing to
take the knight out so I was I was
prepared to do something like this and I
was I believe I was voicing in the video
even if I lose this pawn these guys are
really weakened hmm it says white is a
tiny bit better but I really don't mind
this position at all for black
I think these are going to be
problematic for life
okay well after
structural change I go back home and ya
see five pretty much needs to be played
or night 2d2 preparing to challenge the
night one way or the other
my night never even got challenged
really no maybe I like didn't appreciate
the strength of this piece on c5 that
must have been what it is I don't know C
5 C 5 and then yeah this capture I think
I could even go with Knight d7 yeah so I
give him I would give white a passed
pawn but I could I think I was saying I
could work on the dark squares somehow
Queen Queen on d6 night on c5
this guy's frozen and then I could still
even think about working with the
kingside majority
all right well c5 wasn't played so now
becomes critical like this is this is
already a very important moment c5 and
I'm close to having a complete lockdown
on the position
and that's how it went
I mean once that one
I had that strong night on c5 yeah
nothing was really given up I want to
just test out the one tactic right here
I went with Bishop to d7 forgetting at
this moment that I could capture the
pawn it doesn't even like that I should
have still at least considered it Knight
takes e5 I'm just I'm better in this
position I don't know I just didn't want
even want to give this kind of value to
the pawn connected passer wolf
what's this Queen to e3 Wow okay not b6
b6 and then Queen takes here okay
alright well I didn't take on h3 there
Queen f4 and now in this position I
think it is very good and I guess it's
just all downhill from here
so if Knight takes e5 in this position I
could take on g2 and then yeah this is
this is the two-point pawn Queen still
on the board you don't have your your
Jeep on this problem and a knight I
don't think there's much more to comment
on yeah it's just a a controlled
position and I slowly improve one
decision point here it's important I
mean I look at all the Tempe I put into
doubling the rooks on the e-file got to
make sure it opens it up justify these
moves
so they're brought to life and I don't
know I guess they have your pick f2 is
apparently best
but it's it's just gone anyhow at this
point okay well I'm not sure what more
to really add I just wanted to keep it
squeaky clean in this end game if it did
continue I don't know
king improvement king D seven you know
the King has just cut off I could go for
this and then that even something like
this and still winning but
probably go after this pawn and then
race this guy is simple enough don't
even give up the exchange this pawn will
fall as soon as the knight moves okay
well this is as far as akka
after king to e8 team white resigned all
right feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye
you